[Music]
well another movie I can't wait to see a
star is born the Bradley Cooper Lady
Gaga big-screen remake has already
generated plenty of award show buzz
since the trailer dropped earlier this
summer and for this duo while the
chemistry was instant this was one of
those experiences that I have no doubt
that we're in it for life it was just
magical you know it's it's wonderful to
be a part of something that is this
magnificent but it's a whole other level
when it's that honest and and it's
that's just completely rare he was
mesmerised by her voice but she had no
idea about his until they were first
together all of a sudden he starts
singing and I stopped playing piano and
I was like Bradley you have such an
incredible voice maybe it's time
we instantly started harmonizing and it
was just kind of this magical moment in
the new issue of Entertainment Weekly
Gaga reveals she had to audition for the
role of an unknown singer who falls for
an alcoholic rock star I think you're
beautiful if you're lucky enough you you
find love and you have the loss of love
in your life and it and it invokes in
you the the highest highs and the lowest
lows it's no surprise there's a Ward
buzz Gaga already has a Golden Globe on
her shelf for American Horror Story
hotel and at the time told et acting was
her first love I wanted to be an actress
before I wanted to be a musician
[Music]
[Applause]